si monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'agriculture
nous avons remis un rapport
d'information sur la loi et galim adopté
à l'unanimité le 30 octobre 2019
à la suite de cette adoption le
président du groupe de suivi daniel
grenier a déposé une ppl pour
modestement corriger quelques effets
pervers de cette loi concernant
l'encadrement des promotions malgré le
vote unanime en séance de cette ppl
le ministre de l'agriculture avec une
logique qu'on pourrait comprendre à cet
arc boutés contre en disant faut qu'on
attende la fin de l'expérimentation qui
aura lieu fin 2020 même si je suis en
désaccord sur le fond parce qu'il y
avait urgence ou pourrait comprendre la
logique là où ça se complique c'est
lorsqu'on voit arriver la loi asap ici
avec un article 44 dans lequel le
gouvernement demande aux parlementaires
de se prononcer pour habiliter le
gouvernement par ordonnance s'il vous
plaît d'allonger de 30 mois
l'expérimentation sans aucune autre
explication
donc on a souvent du mal monsieur le
premier ministre à comprendre la logique
de google
votre gouvernement et ma question est
simple je voudrais la comprendre dans ce
cas précis